اذا نحن امام الاقتحام الرابع
لمخيم في اسبوعين ما الذي يجري الان في
طولكرم نعم بالفعل بدات العمليات العمليه
العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال في مدينه طولكرم
وسط اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه وانفجارات
لعشرات العبوات الناسفه باليات الاحتلال
العسكريه التي اقتحمت المخ يم من المنطقه
الغربيه حاجز 104
باتجاه المنطقه الشماليه من المدينه دوار
شويكه الكرم وصولا الى مخيم نور شمس القوه
الثانيه التي خرجت وصلت الى المستشفيات
الفلسطينيه مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي حيث
نتواجد في هذه اللحظات وايضا مستشفى
الزكاه في المدينه حيث حاصر الاحتلال
المستشفيين ويجري عمليات تمشيط في محيط
هذه المست المستشفيات يذكر ان مستشفى ثابت
ثابت الحكومي في كل
اقتحام كان يحاصره الاحتلال من كافه
المحاور الاقتحام السابقين فقط لم يقم
الاحتلال بذلك في هذه اللحظات قوات
الاحتلال تحاصر مخيم طول كرم المتاخم
لمخيم نور شمس بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه
العسكريه في مخيم نور شمس والتي تاتي في
ال في نفس الاسبوع او او خلال اسبوع و في
الاقتحام الرابع الذي يشهده المخيم ومدينه
طول كرم في هذه الاثناء اصوات الانفجارات
لم تهدا حتى هذه اللحظه وايضا الاشتباكات
من عده محاور الاشتباك لم يقتصر فقط في في
المخيمات وانما هناك اشتباكات وانفجارات
في عده احياء من المدينه بالتزامن مع
استمرار وصول الاحتلال والتعزيزات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الى محيط مخيم نور
شمس هنا نرصد في هذه الصوره اليات
الاحتلال العسكريه التي تتواجد في هذه
الاثناء
وتحاصر مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي من كافه
المحاور هناك عدد من الاليات العسكريه
التي تحاصر المستشفى من الجهات الاربعه في
هذه اللحظات وايضا هناك حصار واسع لمخيم
طول كرم المتاخم لهذا المستشفى في وسط
اشتباكات مسلحه لا تزال تسمع بين الفينه
وال اخرى وانفجارات متتاليه حتى هذه
اللحظه ايضا مستشفى
ايه مستشفى الزكاه في مدينه طول كرم الذي
يشهد حصار واسع وانتشار للقناصه في محيطه
هذا يعني ان الاحتلال يحاول منع مركبات
الاسعاف من الوصول الى المستشفيات او
الخروج منها وبالتالي من الممكن ان يؤدي
الى ارتفاع عدد الشهداء والاصابات في ظل
استم رار الاحتلال وتعنت الاحتلال السماح
للاسعاف الفلسطيني في من الخروج او الخروج
من المستشفه
باتجاه المخيمات بالتزامن مع اطلاق
استغاثه من داخل مخيم نور شمس بوجود
اصابات في المنطقه على ما يبدو لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يتم التاكيد بشكل قطعي لكن
هناك حديث من داخل المستشفى ونداءات
استغاثه ل طواقم الاسعاف بضروره التوجه
الى مخيم نور شمس بالتزامن مع استمرار
العمليه العسكريه التي لا تزال متواصله
حيث يحاصر الاحتلال حي المنشيه وايضا حي
المحجر في المنطقه حي المحجر الذي شهد في
الاقتحام السابق قبل ايام قليله فقط
وخلال هذا الاقتحام كان هناك استهداف
لمجموعه من الشبان ادى لارتقاء عدد من
الشهداء واصابه عدد اخر منهم ايضا في في
المنطقه العليا هناك تمركز لاليات
الاحتلال العسكريه التي تظهر في هذه
الصوره هذا يؤكد مضي الاحتلال في عمليه
الحصار للمستشفيات الفلسطينيه في هذه
الليله في مدينه طول كرم وضمن سياسه
الاحتلال المتواصله لا لاعدام الفلسطينيين
ميدانيا اذا ما تم او استمر هذا الاغلاق
فبالتالي لم يتمكن او لن يتمكن اي اي من
الاصابات من الوصول الى هذا المستشفى
والامر حقيقه لا يقتصر فقط
على المستشفيات وانما ايضا
على المصابين هنا على الجهه الاخرى وصول
تعزيزات اسرائيليه جديده الى المستشفى لو
المصور ينقل لنا هذه الصوره لعدد من
الاليات العسكريه التي تصل في هذه اللحظات
الى المحيط المستشفى من اجل اغلاقه واطباق
الخناق والحصار عليه بشكل كامل في هذه
اللحظات اذا عدد بالفعل عدد من الاليات
العسكريه التي تصل في هذه الاثناء الى هنا
الى مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي في هذه
الصوره ونرصد اذا عدد من الاليات العسكريه
التي لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه تصل ضمن
سياسه الاحتلال وايضا وسط اشتباكات مسلحه
لا تزال تسمع حتى هذه اللحظه هنا في هذه
المنطقه وفي محيط مخيم طول كرم وايضا مخيم
نور شمس الذي كما تحدثنا يشهد منذ ايه
اشهر لربما وتزايدت منذ السابع من اكتوبر
لعمليات الاقتحام والاستهداف للكل
الفلسطيني في مدينه طول كرم كما باقي مدن
الضفه الغربيه المحتله